link's awakening on Nintendo switch
maybe a remake but that doesn't mean
it's the same exact game if you've never
played the original or you need a
refresher here are 9 tips to help you
along your adventure if you haven't
noticed yet there are a lot more
seashells and Link's Awakening for the
Nintendo switch than the gameboy version
while these collectables don't have much
of a use in the beginning you'll
eventually come across the seashell
mansion this house lets you trade in the
seashells you've found for rewards I
don't want to spoil the prizes for
collecting seashells but they will prove
useful during your adventure so make
sure to stop by
one of the most useful additions to the
switch version are map markers sure the
island in Link's Awakening is much
smaller than Hyrule proper but there are
a lot of caves and areas you want to
return to later on the easiest way to
remember is to drop a marker like many
older Zelda games Link's Awakening has a
trading sequence that spans most of the
game I won't spoil the exact sequence
here but if you find or see an odd item
like this Yoshi plushie you should
probably get it in order to beat the
game you'll need to complete the entire
trading sequence so keep this in mind as
you progress this might go without
saying but if you're having trouble
finding a key in a dungeon listen for
your compass to chime there are a lot of
keys that you won't find in chests so if
you enter a room and hear a chime that
means there's a key waiting to be found
[Music]
980 rupees in order to get the bow might
seem steep but there are some quick ways
to get a ton of money in Link's
Awakening the most efficient
money-making mini game is called rapids
raid once you get to this part of the
map talk to this guy for 100 rupees you
can either race or raid while you should
do both we recommend starting with the
raid on most runs we made 200 rupees and
refilled our supplies if you're unsure
about what to do or where to go next
check the memory screen by pressing X
with the map open this tracks speeches
from The Owl and other key characters as
well as the amount of locations and
collectables you found unlike in most
Zelda games if you die in Link's
Awakening a bottled ferry won't
automatically revive you instead you'll
need crazy Tracey's secret oink mint you
can buy the medicine directly from her
but keep in mind the price does
fluctuate you can also find the medicine
in certain dungeons as well so keep a
lookout
[Music]
if you're a completionist make sure to
check the shop and the crane game house
frequently as you purchase or win
different items new ones will take their
place so if you're having trouble
finding the last few seashells or heart
pieces then stop by may village it's
also worth stopping in at the shop if
you're low on arrows bombs or magic
powder Link's Awakening DX
added a secret dungeon called the color
dungeon and it's back for the switch
version there's a useful prize in it for
those who managed to find it and
complete it I won't say where it is or
what you'll get but if you're having
trouble finding the dungeon maybe stop
by made villages library and read up on
the island there you have it those are
some of the tips we found useful if you
have any advice for new or returning
players feel free to leave them in the
comments thank you so much for watching
and stay tuned game spot for more of
zelda links awakening
[Music]